فاز الفنان السعودي فايز بن جريس بجائزه
افضل فنان صاعد عن فئه المسلسلات بعد دوره
في المسلسل الشهير رشاش اليوم النجم
الصاعد بيصعد اكثر ما شاء الله وفي رمضان
وقبل وفي رمضان وقبل يعني في رمضان هذا
بطل وكمان قبل رمضان بطل ايضا ففايز لسه
تبيض بندر فيه منه ولدنا اثنين والمسلسل
هذا مكسر الدنيا بخفه دمه وقربه من
المشاهد
امي زي ما هي امك لا
بعيدي بيت يا ولد
ريان نفسه هو اللي استقبل اكيد
والمشاهدات ماليه المنصات في عمل اخر
مؤخرا كمان لفايز مخليه متصدر الساحه وقبل
الموسم الرمضاني شارك فيه بطوله تحديد
المسلسل دكه العبيد بشخصيه ذيب المسلسل من
كتابه وتاليف هبه مشاري حماده وبتدور قصته
في اطار اجتماعي تشويقي ببدايه القرن
العشرين وبتكلم عن خمس قصص مؤثره لشخصيات
مختلفه باماكن متعدده مثل الهند وافريقيا
واوروبا الشرقيه والجزيره العربيه وحقق
نجاح كبير ونسب مشاهدات عاليه
عمك
ما شاء الله
يا مرحبا ومساله
اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا
الله يخليك تسلم بتحتاج
البرودوسر انك ما تكلمت عنه قلت بس الشيخه
ساره فزينه بتحتاجكم
الجميع شيوخ يا مرحبا فيكم كلكم والله
شكرا لك فايز خليني ابتدي من اللي قبل
رمضان يمكن لانه دكه العبيد كان عمل مختلف
تماما تماما تماما تماما احنا متعودين من
هبه مشاري حماده على اعمال خلينا نقول
فيها جدل فيها تعدد في القصص فيها تعدد في
الادوار وتداخل كيف دخل او كيف بدات معاهم
في هذا المشروع
والله يا طويله العمر جاني تجربه اداء
وكنت مره متحمس لاني كنت متابعه شكلها
الكاتب الجميل
ومتحمس جدا يوم عرفت ان الكتابه هذه لها
والمخرج جميل اسعد الوصلات في فتحت اكثر
اني اكون بارت من العمل هذا والحمد لله
توفقنا يكون ذيب
والان لما نتصورتوه قديش كان صعب تصوير
ولا انه صراحه يعني باين انه الضخم عدد
الكاس كبير جدا يعني قديش كان صعب
والله العمل كان جدا جدا صعب بس الحمد لله
التعب منسي لما تشوف رده فعل الجمهور
واعجابهم بالعمل تنسى
ورده الفعل كانت واضحه يعني الناس عبروا
عن اعجابهم يعني بالمسلسل وحيكون فيه طبعا
انتم بتشتغلوا الان حاليا على الجزء
الثاني صحيح صحيح
بتصويره حاليا طيب بعض الناس قالوا العمل
جريء او خادش للحياه حسيت هذا الشيء او
يعني
بس لما تجيب قصه واقعيه لازم تجيب جميع
الاطراف اللي تتكلم عن القصه واقعيه ما
تخرج عشان تكون واقعيه انت ما تبغى واقعيه
مشاهد انا قاعد
كصانع محتوى او كصانع فيلم او مسلسل احنا
نجيب
مثلا اخدش للحياه زي ما بعد الناس اتهموا
او كده
والله كل واحد له رايه خاص ونظره الخاصه
وكل واحد يتفق انه مثلا انا اتفق انه حياه
ايه رايك الشخصي في ناس تشوفها غير حادث
في الحياه راي شخصي بس انا اقول لك هذا
مسلسل واقعي فلازم اطلق الواقع اللي فيه
عشان انت كمشاهد تصدقني هو على العموم
اصلا كان في جدل يعني على حتى مواقع
التواصل يعني على هذا الموضوع خليني اقول
لك على من هو ولدنا يعني نجاح الجزء الاول
خلاكم تعملوا الجزء الثاني كيف وجدت الجزء
الثاني
طبعا
انا مستمتع جدا من ولدنا الجزء الاول
والثاني بوجود المخرج جميل
بوجود الكاتب الجميل بوجود المنتج جميل
وجميع طاقم العمل كممثلين
نتمنى ان شاء الله هو الان قاعدين نعرض
فيه اختلافات اراء بس انا اقول لهم مسلسل
في بدايه حاليا ومتاكد باذن الله خلال
الحلقات الجايه راح يعجبهم كثير لانه الان
الان في الحلقات هذه بدت الحرب بين ريان
وبندر فراح تصير باذن الله انه الناس
كانوا جالسين بيتكلموا وبيقولوا لا الجزء
الاول احلى
صحيح في في ناس كتير تقول للجزء الاول
احلى بس ما نقدر الا لما ينتهي الجزء
الثاني لانه بالجزء الاول فبداياته
ما تحكم على العمل لننتهي طب فايز ايش
ابرز عيوب ابراهيم الحجاج
والله ابو حجاج بالنسبه لي انا انا ما
اقدر اذكر عيوبه لا لا انا ما ابغى محاسن
ما ابغى مديح ابغى عيوب
ما امدح هو عارف
اقسم بالله انه انسان رائع وجميل سواء على
الصعيد الشخصي ولا الصعيد التمثيل يعني
مره مره على حبه بعيدا عن الاخوه انا
اتكلم الان كواحد متابع وشاهد بالنسبه لي
هو واحد من افضل الكوميديين حاليا
بالسعوديه اذا ما كان افضل تبين مدحته انا
كنت حابه كذا يعني اني نعمل له حركات كذا
وننتقده يعني اعرف نزعلك عشان اقدر اخش
ههه
اقول قولي مقلبه عشان اقدر مقلبه
اطلع من قلبك كده
المديح طيب خلاص ايش نسوي نمشيها له هو
وحبوه بصراحه يعني بس ايش بدي اسوي طيب
انت ان شاء الله كمان عندك مسلسل كمان
نازل اللي هو عرب ستاند برضو انتاج ضخم
ايضا صحيح
بالنسبه لي عمل مختلف تماما على اللي
سويته وبالنسبه لظهورك عرب ستاند راح يكون
مفاجئ لكن هو مبني على كتاب شهير وناجح
يعني جدا قصه
اسامه المسلم المعروف ما يعرف الجميل كان
في ثلاث مخرجين العمل جدا جدا جدا ضخم من
اضخم الاعمال اللي ممكن شارك فيها الفتره
اللي فاتت
مخيف اتمنى باذن الله يكون ناجح والمتوقع
مختلف تماما عن الاشياء اللي مثلتها سابقا
الناس تستغرب انه هذا فايز عشان اشياء
كثيره صارت في العمل والشكل لا هو اصلا
ادوارك في الفتره الاخيره يعني فايز مره
مختلفه عن بعد صراحه يعني انت بتحرص انك
انت تعمل اختلافات فيها طيب خليني انقلك
على موضوع ثاني فايز تلاحظ انت يعني انه
اغلب يعني متابعينك او المعجبين فيك بنات
صح
الحمد لله
[ضحك]
ماشي الموضوع مع المعجبات يعني هي بركه من
الله اول حاجه كل مشاهد او كل متابع له
نظره الخاصه
تابعوني سواء عشان التمثيل سواء عشان
اللي اقدمه بشكل عام الحمدلله
والله فيك في كثير اللي يعني انا ما احب
اذكر شكلي من جهه
التمثيلات ولا بشكل عام احاول اني اجيب
شخصيه تخلي الناس تقول اوكي الكلمه قاعد
تملح ما احب ابدا اظهر بشكل هذا احب اظهر
بس احاول
دحين الان في مسلسلات كثير ناجحه اللي هي
دايما كده بتقوم على قصه علاقه انه حب
ومدري ايش وكذا ما حاولوا انه يعملوا لك
وياخذوك في هذا المنحه يعني والله يعني في
في اشياء تقدمت لي بس انا قاعد احاول
اتجنبها لانه ما ودي اخش في الطريق هذا
لاني بعلق بالطريق هذا والناس بتشوفني
بالطريق هذا انا بشكل كبير للدراما
والاكشن بشكل مره كبير وبتعمق باذن الله
بالدراهم بشكل عام ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله طيب في اسئله كثيره على موضوع انه هل
انت خاطب هل انت متزوج هل بتعيش قصه حب كل
هذه التفاصيل تحب توضح اي منها والله
مبدئي ماني مخاطب ولا متزوج حاليا
زمان ذكرت هذا لانهم قالوا متزوج انا
شخصيا متزوج ولا خاطب حاليا والثالثه
تتحفظ عليها
طبعا
طيب على فرحك يعني يا فايز
باذن الله خلص انا اول الحاضرين ان شاء
الله
الله يخليك فايز طبعا احنا دائما بنتمنى
لك كل التوفيق وكل الخير وان شاء الله
يعني انا عارفه انك انت بتصور كمان في هذه
الايام فالله يعينك كمان شكرا لك نورتنا
كان معنا الفنان فايز شكرا لك
[موسيقى]